hey there i'm philip milena and welcome
to our first breakdown of game of
thrones season 6 episode 1 the red woman
for those of you new to the breakdowns
that we do on the channel i'm [ __ ] each
week i will walk us through some
in-depth analysis of the episode i'll do
some general Game of Thrones series I'll
reveal some interesting connections to
the books and I'm gonna point out a few
things that you might have missed on
your first viewing of the episode so sit
back get comfortable and let's dive in
where we always do with a closer look at
the opening images we open on a wall or
actually the wall but as we know in
general a wall is a border or boundary
or just a line marker between what's
here and what's not here and the
character that we see in this moment Jon
Snow he's on the other side of a wall
that's the wall that separates life from
death also note he is as close to that
wall as you can possibly be but it's a
wall of is he dead or isn't he dead
right now if you know your Shakespeare
this is here isn't he stuff might remind
you of our boy Hamlet debating which one
of those is better in his famous to be
or not to be speech and Shakespeare
marks the difference between life and
death
just like the way our wall works here
because Hamlet talks about the state
after death being the undiscovered
country from whose Bourn no traveler
returns now obviously on the show that
sounds a lot like the unexplored lands
north of the wall from which the writers
never return except John Snow he kind of
had the history of going beyond the wall
and yet still somehow returning I've
been worrying about John for years he
always comes back so does that mean he's
coming back no well not in this episode
at least and that mystery about what's
gonna happen to this body that is you
know formerly known as John Snow
that's what this whole episode is about
what happens to us after we die but
mostly what about the people around the
person that's died what kind of plans do
they make for our bodies and for
themselves now before we move on I want
to point out one more thing about these
opening season 6 images of a wall if
you've ever studied a game of Thrones
map which be honest if you're watching
an in-depth analysis of Game of Thrones
you probably studied the maps so you'll
notice that north of the wall there's
not a lot of detail and again it's that
undiscovered country it's Terra Nova for
you nan
and speakers that means new land but
what's interesting because the show is
now ahead of the books then the show
itself is now crossing this same border
without the guide of george RR martin
helping map out the way so it cross your
fingers because out there is the
darkness like any good red priest knows
the night is dark and full of terrors so
hopefully the show runners can light our
way Oh sidenote terra nova was the name
of an early 1900s rish expedition to
explore a new land that later became
known as antarctica and not only is that
another cold place full of ice and where
winter is always coming but that
expedition party they traveled beyond
their walls to Terra Nova and they all
died none of those people came back the
undiscovered country from whose Bourn no
traveler returns as we pan away from the
wall we begin hearing the howling of the
wind but really it's set to transform to
the howling of John's dire wolf whose
kind of living up to his name because it
sounds almost like the spooky howls of a
ghost so here's what's great about how
prominent ghost is in this episode
there's actually a lot going on here
about the relationship with dire wolves
each of the stark children was given a
direwolf and has a special connection to
each one in the books you actually come
to realize that it's not just brand that
sees through the eyes of his wolf all of
the stark children frequently think
they're dreaming but they're actually
seeing through the eyes of their wolves
they've got this very strong link to
them I don't know if you remember but
that's why when people would talk about
Robb in battle they would say that he
and his wolf gray wind they were
perfectly in sync together and I
mentioned that relationship because
something easy to miss here is that they
shared a moment really parallel to this
one as the red wedding was happening it
was gray wind outside the twins pounding
on a door knowing that it was his spirit
human that had been betrayed same things
happening here the other thing to point
out about the dire wolves in these
Starks is that their names have slowly
become more meaningful with regard to
the fate of the stark children
Rickon himself never got to go through
the education and preparation for
lordship that his siblings did and so
he's out there somewhere being raised by
a wildling woman and thus instead of a
proud noble wolf he's become more like a
shaggy dog Arya always dreamt of being a
warrior and her
wolf is named after the warrior queen
Nymeria if you remember that wolf was
set free to go be it's wild self just
like aria has left her family and
embraced her own wildness we already
talked about rob and gray wind but it is
worth noting that not only were they
described as Bheem as relentless and
Swift as the wind while in battle but
your wind it refers to the words that
you speak or the oaths that you make and
it was because Rob made what's supposed
to be a pretty black and white ode into
a murky gray wind that he came upon his
demise now bran has summer which
visually connects us best with the image
of the life filled warm heart tree at
the top of the hill that he's currently
under but also summer is the best bet to
repel the winter and the cold magic
that's coming with that Santa had lady
witch like aria and I Maria was just a
dream of what's always wanted to be but
remember lady died very early on and
when Sansa let go of her childish dreams
of being a dainty lady she actually
began to finally come into her own
obviously we're gonna get back to Sansa
later but that leaves us with Jon Snow
and ghost so did you get ahead of me
here ghosts are what remain after death
but more notable they're literally
people that somehow stay around after
they die if the Wolves predicted the
fate of the Starks John is destined to
be a sort of ghost by still inhabiting
this world after his death we'll just
have to wait and see when that freakin
happens okay now our next miserable
moment did you catch how long Davos
stares at the blood left in the snow
after John's body was moved I definitely
see what looks like a wolf on the left
there and I definitely cannot see what a
lot of people think is a dragon on the
right like where I do not see it but I
understand why people want to believe
there's a dragon there and maybe there
is even though I don't see it but as we
go into this series that some of you
might know I'll say that this could end
up being a big spoiler so skip ahead to
this time if you don't want to know but
a lot of people think that Jon Snow who
Ned Stark claims as his bastard son is
actually the son of Ned's dead sister
Lyanna and if you remember she was
supposedly kidnapped and raped by
Rhaegar Targaryen who was the Mad King
son and Dany a Viserys his older brother
some people think that Rhaegar and
Lyanna were actually engaged in a
forbidden love affair since Rhaegar was
married to Elia the one that the
mountain raped and murdered and Liana
was supposed to marry Robert Baratheon
this alleged rape and kidnapping is why
Robert started his rebellion that led to
him becoming King but anyway the theory
is that when Ned was rescuing Liana he
found her already dying supposedly from
the abuse from Rhaegar but probably from
just childbirth and that there was this
little baby John there and that Ned
promised lianna to not tell people that
he was the son of a stork in a Targaryen
so Ned like Littlefinger did with Sansa
pretends that he has his bastard child
out of wedlock which would be very out
of character for this noble Ned Stark
and that's why people are hoping to see
a wolf and a dragon there cuz that would
probably confirm his mother and father
up next we see Melisandre who you might
be thinking hey that's the red woman
that's who this episode is named after
but I'd actually say hey stop shouting
at your screen but also I think the
title of this episode isn't really just
about her in fact I'll come back to it
but I think it's mostly about the red
women you'll see what I mean as we move
forward but back to this moment for a
second I just want to point out one
easy-to-miss detail note how much more
bundled up Melisandre is here then
recently when she was bragging to Jon
Snow you know cold milady never
the Lord's fire lives within me Jon Snow
it looks like she's not feeling that
same internal heat at this moment that
would make a lot of sense as to why
she's feeling so low already and then
did you catch what she said she looks at
John's body and she says he's hiding it
winter obviously she feels so down
because that never ended up happening
her flames were wrong except I'm gonna
put out that maybe she's not wrong it
just might not have happened yet if you
remember right now the Bolton's hold
Winterfell and just like they said this
episode a lot of people are gonna want
to take it from them who better than a
newly resurrected Jon Snow to take back
his home actually if you like that
theory I'm gonna give you a bonus one
here there are a lot of rumors that Robb
Stark left a will which makes sense as
he was king of the north and as king and
as the head of a household how stark he
very easily could have left it in that
will that upon his death Jon Snow was to
be legitimized as John Stark and become
the rightful heir and Lord of Winterfell
so it would actually become his duty to
do what Melisandre saw in the flames and
go fight to win back Winterfell then we
stop in with Sir Alliser thorne and he
gets a pretty effective speech actually
to his men loyalty is the foundation on
which the Nights Watch is built and it's
only worth noting that when Julius
Caesar was betrayed his assassins used
that exact same logic he was gonna use
his power to inadvertently destroy Rome
just like thorne is saying snow would
have done to the watch Jon Snow was
going to destroy the Nights Watch
after that we're actually taking a
Winterfell to see Ramsay pay his
respects to his ex Miranda and this shot
is actually a direct match for the shot
of Jon Snow's face showing that in death
we are all the same the corpses are no
different but the plans made by those
around the corpse that's where you find
the differences and again that's
basically what this episode is about the
aftermath of death so it's really Ramsay
who we learn more about who even when he
seems to have a heart for a second and
he pains for her is it what is it his
plan head for the body
she's good meat see the two pounds he
wants to feed her to the dogs man I
would love to see the resurrected Jon
stark riding in a Winterfell I've been
giving Ramsay some of his own medicine
he has this fondness of sending hounds
after people so you got a love
that image of him being eaten alive by
ghosts like maybe he would end up
looking like his house sigil here's
hoping
speaking of house Bolton just a quick
explanation about ruses statement about
his new wife's baby he's just reminding
him that if Ramsay's a failure and his
new baby is a boy then he'll make the
baby the heir to the Bolton name instead
of Ramsay that's all moving on we see
Sansa and reek / Theon's escape and they
actually touch on our theme when Sansa
doesn't want to cross the water because
she thinks it'll kill her and Theon lets
her know that sure yeah death is equal
to death but what dogs do to a body
rather than the cold that's a much
uglier way to go and that also leads to
this really sweet moment where Theon old
Sansa to help warm her but it ends up
kind of becoming a really messed-up
version of just an affectionate hug it's
fitting that they're sitting where they
are because as far as these two know
they're the only children of Winterfell
left and even though they're not
technically related they're the closest
thing they have to actual family I
remember that's why Theon actually gave
Sansa away at her wedding to Ramsay so
this twisted uprooted mess of a tree
it's a lot like what's become of their
weirdo family tree that they now share
okay then we get this pretty cool fight
of where Brienne and pod save the day
and pot it's clearly learned a lot about
fighting from Brie and I'm just gonna
quickly point out that this beyond
saving pod is like a full circle moment
for one pod save Tyrion that was when
pod entered manhood by the way so this
could be the moment that reek is gone
and Theon has returned to manhood
something that was literally taken from
him also this moment after the fight
where Santa exchanges the same vows that
Brienne and Catelyn exchanged in season
two was amazing
I vow that you shall always exist in my
home and I know those of you that like
bringing dishonor it might bring me to
something it's incredibly rare on this
show to see a moment it's just this
hopeful I predicted before this season
that the Starks would rally and it's
really feeling like it's gonna happen
also this was a moment I was alluding to
earlier about Sansa and her dire wolf
lady Sansa had her fake version of being
a lady she wanted to marry Joffrey she
had a big crush on the gay knight of
flowers entertaining that possibility of
being little
lady was just more of dislike fake
illusion of what a lady is but it's not
until she dumps all of that lets the
fantasy version of a lady died with her
wolf and now not until she actually
fights for her life and gets down and
dirty does she finally get to preside at
the head of a household she is now the
lord of the Starks at this moment though
the proper title is what she had to walk
away from before she is now lady Stark
it's extra touching to remember that in
this moment that feels a lot like a
wedding actually pods like the hood the
priest or something she's got some
connection to her father being here as a
witness
Brienne sword is Oathkeeper which was
made from the Valyrian steel that was
provided when Tywin had Ned Stark's
sword ice melted down he's right there
in that little sword and oh man if you
were not crying tears of joy after that
moment by the way how about some tears
of sorrow when you watch Cersei go from
running blissfully to the harbor to the
opposite drama mass of just straight-up
tragedy her face she's just so resigned
it having a terrible life now these
shots indicate how alone she feels in
this moment especially when you realize
they're purposely being mirrored - when
Marcella left back in season two but now
she's just so alone and after that walk
that ended last season I cannot imagine
Cersei being any more broken like this
is rock-bottom except as she goes into
the prophecy which opened last season by
the way you're reminded that which
foretold that all of her children would
die so she still might lose Tommen and
if that happens I think she is literally
just she's gonna go crazy like just
straight-up crazy earth her story about
her mother's dead body and then
wandering about Marcela's is yet another
example of the aftermath after the death
of loved ones it's a skin ton black the
lips peel back from her teeth a reaction
tells us that Cersei sees death as
corruption it destroys all that was good
her golden mother and golden children
are gonna be ruined and bloated and
decayed she sees death as a punishment
which makes sense when you hear that she
sees herself as a monster who does
terrible things she's not wrong either
moving on Jamie makes us super pumped
for a vengeance storyline
and weirdly something about this scene
makes us kind of root for this very
unusual once very hateable couple and
then we're on to septa unella shaming
yet another queen and as she reads from
the seven pointed star the Bible of the
faith of the seven and she makes Margery
flinch it's all reminiscent of the times
in history where religious frenzy took
over like the Spanish Inquisition when
Catholics in Spain tortured people for
not being Catholic enough and the
Puritans in Massachusetts with their
Salem witch trials and unfortunately
also in just parts of the world today
also after Margery admits that she's a
sinner the high Sparrow tells her many
miles to go possibly foreshadowing a
walk of shame for her - okay then we go
to Dorne and everything goes to hell
we see a bloody power grab but it
mirrors the betrayal of a leader trying
to make the wise choice rather than the
popular one last episode it was at the
northernmost point of Westeros and now
it's down at the far south so from top
to bottom Westeros is not really a place
that values wisdom very much by the way
if you're wondering what kind of letter
Jaime might have sent Prince Doran to
announce the murder of his only daughter
it's a surprisingly chill one you can
read it for yourself here now to be fair
he does very casually ask for a lorry as
head and I gotta admit I'm a little
frustrated by ilaria here because her
plan to avenge Oberyn for a death from a
battle he agreed to take part in it
requires her slaughtering his whole
family once again we are seeing how the
death of a person is reacted to
differently by those left behind but I
feel like her reaction is just wrong
Oberyn even once said that you don't
hurt little girls I'm doing and that's
exactly what ilaria recently did you
heard a little girl Christine is also
super young and pretty innocent and
oberyn's nephew by the way and boom dead
we didn't know much about him other than
he's a bit of a Romeo - merciless Juliet
but did you notice that his reaction to
being the one left behind by a death was
painting the stones that were gonna be
placed on Marcela's eyes for the funeral
that means that he's caught up in the
almost romantic elements of the funeral
and that big ceremony that's really more
something for the people left behind
than it is for the person who died
because the dead person doesn't really
know
I'll bake their party is you know what I
mean so just one other reaction to a
death I will give ilaria that his
interest in that side of it does kind of
represent her frustration with these
Martell men who react to death in a
pretty passive way they're not like
Oberyn was and how she is so much more
actually just kind of crazy oh also for
those of you wondering like @f estes 451
who tweeted at me where the heck was
trystane when the sand snakes caught up
to him that isn't taking place in Dorne
that's on that boat that's just off of
the coast of King's Landing remember we
saw Jamie and Marcella have their one
sweet moment before was all ruined for
them that's a pretty unlucky boat by the
way but now as for how they got onto
that boat well we know they didn't stow
away because they were still on the dock
when the boat pulled away so I'm
guessing they're just sneaky little
snakes who followed the boat and then
just somehow stayed hidden the whole
time and totally dry I don't know so
what's gonna happen to Dorne well
actually we don't know here's something
interesting though the Martel's are the
ruling House of Dorne represented by the
Sunspear sigil which is also the name of
their castle and Prince Doran was just
killed which would pass his lordship to
trystane but he's dead so would then
pass to Elia and her children but they
were all killed by the mountain then it
would pass to Oberyn but he was also
killed by the mountain he however had no
legitimate heirs so it would go to his
eldest illegitimate heir Obara sand so
does that make Obara head of house
Martell sure but does she rule as lady
of sunspears maybe not remember this is
a coup and in those whoever the military
supports is who really has the power in
this moment it really seems like they
might be in support of ilaria so we'll
see I think it would be cool actually if
there was some debate or even a battle
between them for the final power here
but either way what ilaria said is right
and weak men will never be born again
gonna be a lady also worth noting their
house sigil kind of predicted part of
this because it depicts the Sun being
pierced by a spear exactly what happened
to the princes son also pierced by a
spear and in the books a really big deal
is made about how in Dorne the seat of
power it actually does past
as well as men so while there Marcela
was actually considered the rightful
queen of Westeros because she's older
than Tommen after Joffrey's death it
would have gone to her but honestly the
Dorne storyline is epically different in
the books take in fact you you might
even like it better there
here's a quick tease that I'll give you
in the books Dorne is preparing to take
on the Lannisters by forging a really
important union with somebody else who
has a lot of power and a bone to pick
with the people of King's Landing
Daenerys there's a lot of really cool
stuff going on in the books there by the
way all these differences and that's a
really great reason to read books
especially because the story is pretty
different in some very cool ways for
instance Margaery in the books is not a
prisoner for line it's for a much
spicier reason but also because you get
this way deeper understanding of it all
like the fact that all Starks might be
wards or the prophecies in the books
they're way more detailed and if you
don't have any time to read the books do
like I did and get the audiobooks from
audible.com actually when I got really
impatient by the way I would listen to
them on two x speed because the app lets
you do that and my brain just adjusted
to it so I flew through them like
seriously like I plowed through all the
books in just a couple of weeks by just
listening to the audio books whenever I
had any downtime and the guy who reads
the books like who narrates them he's
really good at doing the voices and
since the story is a bit different there
it all feels kind of like bonus episodes
of the TV show like for instance the
Lady Stoneheart character she's not even
in the show but she's like epic in a way
in the books and I'm not gonna spoil
anything about who she is but I will say
holy crap it's one of the craziest
things that you could imagine happening
in the story and it actually plays into
the themes of this episode about what
happens after death and I wish I could
tell you more but the spoilers are too
big just go listen to the books I sent
audible a letter to tell them how much I
love the books and they hooked us up
with a link to give anyone from our
audience a free 30-day trial and a free
book credit so if you go to audible.com
slash new rockstars you can sign up and
download the first book which is called
Game of Thrones for free you also get
another free book every month after that
so you can easily get the whole series
okay then let's travel across the Narrow
Sea to catch Oba Tyrion and Varys and
I'm not going to point out too much here
because I think it was pretty
straightforward but I am gonna mention
that this scene of Tyrion descending to
where the people actually are is
something he picked up when serving in
King's Landing and something that we
rarely see Daenerys do with all her
scenes taking place in the pyramid this
means he really could teach her a lot
still and they could have a very
powerful alliance I will also mention
that as Varys interion wonder about who
the harpy could be that's planning all
of these attacks and possibly maybe also
the same person that is their resident
Banksy spray-painting graffiti in
English on the walls those shots make us
feel like the two of them are being
watched I actually like that they're
building up this mystery because I hope
it's gonna pay off with a big reveal
here's the theory though could the harpy
be Varys you did show up right as that
stuff started to happen but we will get
to that maybe in the comments moving on
the ships burn and you know there's
another family out there who's really
badass and has so many boats could this
be the way to bring them into the
narrative story if so that means this
year could be about the Alliance's that
Daenerys is gonna need to forge she's
ever gonna march on Westeros and
considering that they're not only like
10 to 15 episodes left after the season
she's got to get a move on like you can
tell that Jorah feels this deadline
approaching - since he wants to see what
happens before his scale takes over I'm
gonna come back to something Daario says
- Jorah in a little bit but in the
meantime let's plow forward we see Danny
captive with the Dothraki and I like how
she looks to the skies while they're
telling their super like bro he jokes
like she's wishing drogon would just
show up and just like fry the hell out
of these guys but what else is
interesting is how far Danny's status
has fallen in the Dothraki world at this
moment she was the Khaleesi now long ago
and it was Viserys who was made to walk
alongside them as a pitiful captive you
walk now it's her then Danny meets this
new Khal called Moro and in the books
he's actually a blood rider of Drogo's
and so it seems like maybe he absorbed
most of drogas power it's actually not
clear if they have that connection here
but he's definitely absorbed a lot of
douchiness from somewhere
aha this debate about how great it is to
see a naked woman it gets a little meta
when you realize that that's actually
why some people watch this show and
probably what they debate about the best
five things about Game of Thrones those
people are probably very surprised by
the end of the episode but we will get
to that something I think is interesting
here is that the
of the Dothraki are both what's saved in
errors from calbro go here even aussie
Kalidas women you know posickey but also
what dams her a moment later to be sent
away to vias dothrae o also Daenerys
here repeats her phrase about never
giving birth again until the Sun rises
in the West and sets in the East when
the Sun rises and I'm not insects in the
East now some people think of that
phrase there's less of a never statement
and more of a prophecy I used to think
that it could be about Dorne maybe with
their Sun sigil but with what happened
earlier now I'm starting to wonder what
if it's another play on the word Sun and
we're talking about the child of someone
who gains power or maybe is raised in
the West but comes to settle in the East
if so who could that be about cuz there
are only so many prominent sons going
around these days
Jorah and tyrion are both prominent sons
i grew up in the west and have now come
to the east but also john is a pretty
prominent son who may not have gone to
the east now but it doesn't mean he
never will hmm let me know what you
think about that in the comments let's
keep going actually just a few things to
point out before we wrap up the episode
we see arya though she doesn't see us
how or anything at all and if you watch
that scene again you might notice that
during that beating all the visual edits
are hitting you at the exact same moment
that the sound of the beating are it's
meant to disorient us and confuse us
just as much as she's disoriented though
I think it's hitting her a lot harder
than it hits us the other thing here is
that she's learning a lot through this
punishment of blindness and if you
listen really closely you hear that the
crime she committed actually did some
good that murder of Meryn Trant is what
these men are talking about as to why
they no longer will ever visits the
house of prostitution that specializes
in children for pedophiles
Kings cousin I added tonic thank you so
but harder to hear there's a woman that
says
which is one of the main mantras of the
house of black and white
considering usually that price that you
pay the death can pay for life then Aria
just being made blind is actually a
pretty good deal for her plus it's
obviously just setting up her getting
some daredevil height powers or at least
that's what that badass warrior Titan in
the background is foreshadowing what
this training is gonna turn her into
this is essentially gonna be part two of
serios lessons and I'm just getting
pretty excited for badass assassin Aria
finally then we're back where we started
at the wall where Davos is being asked
to surrender by thorn and there's this
really great but easily miscible moment
here with Davos he asks thorn from some
mouton like sure it's kind of a
hilariously random request but notice
that after thorn says sure we'll give
you mutton give you food Davos sighs
disappointed and then he tells his men a
moment later that they would have been
killed if they'd opened that door my
Luna de pinion we open that door and
those slaughter so that's because Davos
just tested thorn had thorn said no or
even shown some amount of resistance to
this really weird request for mutton
then his intentions would have been true
that's that's accurate how he would
behave we were taught of truth but being
so quickly agreeable and giving him just
a simple quick yeah sure that tells
Davos said he's only trying to say what
it takes to get that door open and is
probably not gonna make good on any of
these promises and then we're into the
closing images and it's the big reveal
of the episode we see Melisandre take
off her dress and just like Stanley
Kubrick messed with our expectations
about the erotic Peep Show that Jack
Nicholson thought he was going to get in
the shining the show makes us think that
we're gonna get yet another empty nude
scene from the red woman and then it
twists reveals her true form that of a
very very old woman with some theories
placing her anywhere between 100 and 400
years old this is the moment that I was
like those guys that watch the show for
naked ladies probably didn't love this
moment but this is also very Amana
--scent of the transformation of
Disney's Evil Queen which is also a bit
of a witch who works with spells and
potions and also transforms to an evil
woman and she also examines herself in
the mirror but I would say mullah song
isn't back she's actually never been
further from being the villain
than in this moment she's literally
exposed as this fragile creature who's
completely lost her cold white wrinkly
body it mirrors the Sun revealing the
cold white wrinkly wall in the opening
images and right now so much about her
becomes clear finally earlier Dario
tells Jorah that he wishes he can grow
old if you grow if I grow old I hope I
do I want to see what the world looks
like but she's done conquering it you
want to see what happens with the
Daenerys story we all do by the way
buddy but he means it's not a luxury
that people tend to have in that world
you don't grow old you die pretty young
so if she's actually hundreds of years
old then she's seen many winters and
many wars when you're that used to
winter and war then the one that you're
currently living in at this moment it
doesn't seem so momentous she sees the
long view which is why she always feel
so detached from everything everyone
she's ever known has died at some point
so what does it matter if she burned
some people at the stake or if she sends
people to be slaughtered in battle
they're all gonna go sometime she is
thinking of the longer play however now
the things that she saw in the flames
that she had been attributing all her
actions to all that stuff is not coming
true everything she's done cannot be
justified anymore and that realization
it overwhelmingly saddens her but also
that means she's headed into a future
that is completely uncertain and that's
uncharted territory Terranova and that
terrifies her she climbs into bed just
like a child hiding from something bad
they've done or maybe hiding from the
monsters that she thinks might be out
there in the darkness note that she
stays near the fire and bundles up under
the covers because the light in her is
almost completely out she's lost all the
warmth and with that all of the red and
now she just left with the wintery cold
and almost the appearance of a white
Walker to match but before you see all
that as like a sad downer let's remember
what else happened
episode member I kept saying that this
episodes about what people do after a
death what happens to the people left
behind so this episode showed us that by
really focusing on widows a widow by
definition is completely defined by
being the person left behind after the
death of a loved one
so while the red woman and the episode
not being read at all
her red woman qualities are being
redistributed to all of the show's
widows out there and I'll tell you what
I mean by red qualities red represents
lots of things in literature sex passion
danger blood fire death the red woman
herself represents ultimate intensity in
your passionate zealous like faith and
that's all being sent out to different
widows here septa unella enjoys drawing
blood from Marjorie who is twice a widow
and has been defined by the men that
she's been married to and here when she
finally admits to her sins she becomes
faithful to her religion like the red
woman the sand snakes obviously leave a
lot of red in their wake but their
leader ilaria also a widow is
responsible for most of it being spilt
her speech to Doran about his wimpiness
shows her giving in to not logic but the
red passion that it's eager for war and
also it's a reminder of just how
passionate her relationship was with
Oberyn she's letting that consume her
now inversely Daenerys is Khal Drogo's
Widow but since she already had all of
this power of being a queen now she's
having that choice of how to mourn for a
person left behind taken away from her
similarly Cersei another Widow who was
in a high state of power is stripped of
another child who herself by the way she
left this world with red blood pouring
down her face and she took with it
Circe's red passion and red fire as well
however Cersei still gained a red woman
trait in that she now is obsessed with
the fulfillment of prophecies while
Melisandre has lost faith in them by the
way yes most Sandra herself is also a
widow if you remember that her main
partner Stannis has died and her
potential new squeeze is also cold dead
too
finally Sansa who is technically married
to multiple men and has let each of
those marriages die fingers crossed that
we'll actually see one of those exes
dead soon Ramsay she has the red hair
but she as of this episode has the red
woman status her power more than red
she's now a woman in her own right
finally she even quasi marries again but
finally by her own choosing when she
accepts the services of Brean she
chooses the possibility of death rather
than remaining a victim and as the lady
of Winterfell now she's in a position to
potentially end the war in the north
she's rising as Melisandre is falling so
just like the red wedding flipped our
expectations of what a wedding is
supposed to be that bizarro event leads
us to almost bizarro marriages and
bizarro red widows who subvert what
people would expect of widows to be like
after they're left behind by the
supposedly more powerful men these red
widow's aren't going to do what you'd
expect
they're not gonna rot alongside the
corpse or burn themselves on a funeral
pyre they're gonna step up and be
unburned so even though it's ironic that
the least red woman in this episode is
the one we know as the red woman it
makes a lot of sense actually because if
the Lord of light shines his red power
where he pleases
he's momentarily shifted away from her
but to these other women but also
everyone clamoring for Melisandre to use
his light god magic to resurrect Jon
Snow in this episode and they're
disappointed that she didn't you got to
realize that the rest of the women in
this episode have been very heavily
influenced by him instead like I don't
think it's a coincidence that all of our
widows are now being reborn as these
powerful beings it's like despite what
all of us had planned that like God we
knew this about him he does what he
wants and in this situation he chose to
resurrect all of them instead so all of
these women on this show they're all the
ones that are getting resurrected by the
light God right now at least and they've
become the red woman okay but the
questions I'm left with one is
Melisandre being without her faith a
good thing or a bad thing for Jon Snow
does it mean that he's got to find
another way to be resurrected or is it
like how Thoris had lost all of his
faith right before he resurrected beric
Dondarrion it's almost a requirement
maybe - what do you think of the
possibility of Varys being the harpy
let's talk about in the comments 3 a lot
of you are wondering why the red woman
was shown
in a bath without her necklace but
looked young still there do you think
that the mistakes the show made or do
you think it could be something else for
instance could maybe her glamour spell
had something to do with the bottles of
the potion looking stuff that's on the
table and not be about the necklace or
maybe and this could be kind of cool
actually maybe in that old episode she
did look old in that moment to Solis
Stannis's wife if you watch that scene
again she can barely look at her but if
you imagine it's because of how old she
is and kind of gross in a moment and if
that's how Melisandre was able to make
solis in just such a devout believer it
would kind of make sense what do you
think okay so I hope you enjoyed this
breakdown of the game of Thrones Season
Premiere and if you like this please
share it with your friends I would
really love for these to catch on but
also for those of you that have been
following us for a while I really
appreciate you all rooting for us and
watching these things and I know that
the number one request that you all have
is for us to make more videos and get
them out to you faster that's why we
were so pumped when audible.com told us
hey we love your videos how can we help
you so if you've ever wondered how you
can help us out which I know a lot of
you have tweeted that at me and thank
you for asking
here's how you can do it if you sign up
for a free trial at audible.com there's
no risk
you just get a free book to listen to
and if you've already read Game of
Thrones or want to try something else
feel free they've got like a quarter of
a million things to listen to on their
react if you do that and we get enough
signups audibles gonna keep sponsoring
us to get more editors and overnight
editors which would make all the
difference in getting these things out
to you faster so again that is
audible.com slash new rock stars thank
you so much for watching I am so pumped
for this season and breaking it down
with you let's all take off our magical
necklaces and make out I'm just kidding
we'd be so gross bye
you